-Welcome back to
"The Tonight Show," everybody.
I'm Tariq Trotter.
And it's time to play...
-"Password"!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Let's meet our contestants.
And to my left, his movie,
"Paws of Fury:
The Legend of Hank,"
is in theaters now.
It's Michael Cera!
-Oh, no!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Now, Michael, Michael,
my apologies.
Your partner this evening...
-You don't have to say
your apologies.
-...is the host of
NBC's "Tonight Show"
and a Grammy Award-winning
"musician."
-That's right.
-Jimmy Fallon, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-I did win a Grammy.
That was amazing
that ended up on the cue card.
-Guys, your first opponent
is the band leader
for the legendary Roots Crew,
the greatest band
in all of hip-hop history.
-It doesn't say that
on the cue cards at all.
-Say hello to Questlove!
-Oh, that's right!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-And his partner is the host
of the new show on NBC,
"Password,"
which premiers
August 9th at 10:00 p.m.,
after "America's Got Talent."
It's Keke Palmer!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Alright.
I hope the rules
are very simple.
-The rules of the game
I'll give each of you
a password, alright?
And then you are to give
a one-word clue.
That's one. One word only...
-Chill, man.
-...to get your partner
to guess the password.
First clue...
-Ooh, we have to
win this, Quest.
-...goes to Jimmy and Questlove.
-Okay.
-The password is...
-Quest, why don't you
start this off.
-Okay.
Scuba.
-Diver.
-Wait. He nodded.
Is that --
-No, no. I was just --
-That's not right?
-I was saying, "Nice guess."
-Okay.
-It was encouragement.
It was encouragement.
-Okay.
Breathing.
[ Laughter ]
-Wait. Could you say that again?
-No, no, no. He can't.
He can't say it again.
-You heard the first clue.
-Yeah.
-More words. You're --
-No, no, no. That's true.
Okay, no.
There's a couple ways to go,
but I'm going to say...
gear?
-Sorry.
-Gear.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay.
-Wow.
-You heard all the clues, right?
Okay.
-Thought it was gear.
-Goggles.
-Tank.
-I mean...
-I feel like
we're in it, Michael.
-Tube.
-Is that helpful?
-No, it's not.
-Tube! It's so helpful, tube.
-Oh. Snorkel?
[ Dinging, cheering ]
-Wait.
-I mean, like...
-There's no music playing.
-Look...
-Well, you know,
that was just the first round.
-Alright,
that was the first round.
That's fine. It's fine.
We're warming up.
-It's about time.
-Sorry. It could have been
gear, though,
the more I thought about it.
Scuba gear.
-I'm just -- Yeah.
-Yeah.
-I have to work this out.
I got to work on that.
-The next clue
is going to go to Michael.
-Okay.
-Now it's time for us to shine.
-And to Keke.
-I know Keke's good.
-Keke's good.
-The password is...
-Okay.
-Oh.
-Mm-hmm.
-Michael.
-I go first?
-Michael, you're up first.
-Oh, yeah.
-Oh, that's hard.
-Here we go. We got this, bud.
Come on.
Partner, we got this, bud.
We got the first one.
We're going to get
the second one. Here we go.
-Yeah, these are some hard ones.
-Comida.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Excellent.
-Gesundheit? Okay.
-He said, "Gesundheit."
-Comida.
Kitchen?
-You would never get this
one the first clue.
-So, that was Spanish.
-Okay. Yes.
-Oh! You are unbelievable.
You are unbelievable.
-Dish.
-Oh, God.
Comida.
Dish.
-You know.
It's the most popular.
-Oh!
-You got it.
-No.
I got to respectfully pass,
because --
-Not quite.
-Oh, yeah,
like you're gonna get it.
Go ahead. Hit me, hit me.
-I mean, it's a good chance.
-"Respectfully pass."
-Pass?
-I don't even know
if that's allowed.
-I've never heard of
anyone doing it.
-I'm a trendsetter.
-Alright, so, comida, dish.
-Oh, yeah, right.
-If you say one word,
I might say the other word.
-I don't know what
that means, but...
-I know what that means.
-Right?
-Whole.
[ Laughter ]
-No, that's a good one.
-Whole.
-Don't be immature.
-The whole...chimichanga?
-Oh, my God!
-That's a saying?
-But the whole --
-No!
[ Sad tuba plays ]
-Tuba!
-But it's the whole -- Oh!
I know what it is now.
-He knows it now.
-I still don't know it!
-You've got to get this.
You got to.
-Well, depending on your word.
Just say the word.
Say the word.
-Colada. Colada.
-Piña.
Wait! I...
-Whoa-ho-ho! So good.
Enchilada!
[ Dinging, cheering ]
I'm sorry. I'm sorry.
-Without a clue. Without a clue.
-The whole enchilada.
-Enchilada was hard.
-Whole was good.
-Oh, my God.
-The whole...
-Oh! W-H...
Oh, I get it.
-Not the chimichanga.
Yeah, the whole chimichanga.
-You threw me off.
I thought you were making a bean
reference with whole.
-Yeah, the whole -- Yeah.
-Okay, okay, okay.
-Enchilada.
-We're in the game still.
-Alright, here we go.
-The final clue -- the final
clue goes to Michael and Keke.
-Okay.
-Here we go.
This is for
the whole chimichanga.
-The password is...
-Okay.
Oh, God.
-It's on you.
-Is there a theme
with this game today? Okay.
-Okay.
-Is it me?
-Mm-hmm.
-Floss.
-Oh, my goodness.
-Wait. What?
-What?
-Wait. Did she say a word?
-Watch again.
-There was
extra letters in there.
-Yeah, what did you --
What are you doing?
-Take the bubble gum out.
-What are you --
-Floss.
[ Laughter ]
Floss.
-What?!
-Floss? Uh...
toothpick?
[ Dinging, cheering ]
-Oh, my...
My thanks to Keke Palmer,
my partner, Michael Cera,
Questlove, Tariq Trotter.
We are talking to Michael Cera
after the break.
Stick around, everybody.